então tem que querer complementa dos
outros que já conhece todos é só uma
bola pedra e rocha lança os maiores que
outros mas aos mais líquidos mais
gravosos mas há ali uma área ali
qualquer coisa no espaço só quer ser
diferente dos outros por uma casal mas
tem um sistema terrestre e hoje vamos
falar do sistema terrestre ao livro
chama tragédias comuns ligar retarde em
que iam dar um exemplo em que a luta
terreno é usado por 10 pastoso pastor
tem 10 o velho jack é um atraso da 11ª
que fazem os outros fazem todos a 11ª
no total serão 11 eu passo a passo rosa
que copiam ou passar pátria seu campeão
qual é o que vai acontecer o uso comum
desregulada que o terreno da origem aqui
o treino e entrou em colapso
isso resulta na tragédia todas as
janelas como isto é o uso dos ngola vão
bem comum da como origem o velho de
todos e é solução para este tipo de
problema até hoje foi a solução da
divisão isto é se nós pegarmos treino e
cada um fizer a sua parte
como depende daquela sua parte e eu não
vai ultrapassar os limites que sabe que
não pode ultrapassar não é mais de vidro
a sua parte e eu posso usar números em
duas outras marcas
eu não vou pôr a quarta ou quinta porque
isso põe em causa a minha própria sobre
como estar vivido isso que eu não fizer
isso no seu lugar o autor mostrar melhor
e até hoje a solução clássica peça 3l
dos bens comuns foi sempre esta é a
visão organizar o mesmo coisas passa no
nosso planeta por motivos históricos da
comissão política que nós temos é esta
dividimos o território e só que quando
ou divisões fizeram sobre em água
começaram a ter problemas porque mesmo
entre os dois países quando está melhor
agora nós podemos dividir juridicamente
o espaço
nós estamos exibindo juridicamente o
sistema quattro capital e para a
fronteira entre os estados unidos eo
panamá
na década de 80 e as grandes lagos são
os meus lábios do nosso planeta estavam
completamente destruído porque por cada
um usou o aghu usa enquanto tudo isso
porque tudo vai e sei que o time dizendo
que esta é minha parte mas sei que os
danos que eu faço aqui não sou meu sonho
partilhado com o vizinho do lado
entretanto como vocês forma inconsciente
os lagos que eu tenho dentro no país faz
uma gestão cuidada mas aqui eu sei que é
comum
cada um usa o palco cada um primeiro o
primeiro a usar o primeiro filme e
portanto é tragédia dos comuns aqui
nestes lácteos aconteceu é que os dois
consigam chegar a acordo
estados unidos e canadá não é cada um
consigo prever qual é o comportamento o
outro e como eu consegui impor meu
comportamento outros 4 mil e sem eu ter
essa capacidade o primeiro o que não
falta no meio porque eu não vou ser o
atalho
vocês vão perceber que a nível global
passa precisamente o mesmo ninguém vai
ser o otário
ninguém gosta de ser otário e vamos
falar ainda mais o risco que não
identificou suas constituição investiu
pouco jeito que você venha o outro
também ia fazer porque não ia ficar para
trás o que aconteceu aqui deus fizeram
um acordo não tendo em conta o limite da
área jurídica mas abusaram aquela
questão como uma unidade ecossistêmico
aqui a realidade é conjunta a que o
sistema natural que não tem enquanto as
fronteiras duas situações diferentes
uma um treino que nós conseguimos
definir outra um lago que nós não
conseguimos viver isso é normal
acaba por ser o mesmo com você tem as
mesmas políticas todas do planeta e já
na zona econômica exclusiva de cada um
só que além disto além do sistema
terrestre não cabe dentro destas linhas
e temos também já aqui neste mapa
aquilo que hoje é não só em termos do de
termos da área áreas do planeta mas
também temos de alta e tudo isto é em
termos de espaço aéreo da soberania é
sobre tantas milhas marítimas a coluna
d'água prováveis
e toda a área do espaço aéreo que esta
neste caso esta mistura de francisco
prelados digamos assim de titularidade
entre a soberania e as partes comuns
quando estamos aqui falar parte como
estamos aqui e falar neste mapa que já
são patrimônio da madeira neste momento
os fundos marinhos jantar que teve clean
no mesmo vai manter a mente visível ao
planeta já existem dois tipos de
submarinos de titularidade uma comum a
toda a humanidade e outras urânio do
estado elas misturam se estão dentro
mesmo embasamento invisível ao campeão
comigo falou ainda da questão mas coloca
aqui é que este planeta não é apenas uma
rocha no espaço ainda tem mais qualquer
coisa que a área e juridicamente o que
existe é uma área em termos da natureza
os objetos jurídicos a forma como
jurídica sua natureza é em termos da
área
em termos de espécies mas parece o mar e
as planeta tem mais qualquer coisa que
se chama sistema terrestre
juridicamente não existe no entanto não
deixa de ser o nosso bem mais precioso e
que se o nosso planeta dos outros e
assina teste não foi sempre igual ao
longo da sua história nos 46 bilhões de
reais do nosso planeta que acho que é
por muitos estados já temos muitas
diferentes composições que são
estruturas bioquímicas atmosfera ea água
o sol já evoluiu ao longo deste tempo
todo e que só nos últimos dias milan ita
que eu penso que nós chamamos o oceano é
que criar as condições mil químicas no
planeta para potenciar o desenvolvimento
da espécie humana
nós já andamos aqui é mais ou menos
assim 800 mil anos
só nos últimos 10 mil anos é criar as
condições climáticas condições
bioquímica permitiram o momento a nossa
espécie permitiram o desenvolvimento da
civilização
só para ter uma noção como explicar o
sorriso está trabalhando conosco esta
matéria paulo a questão não era do frio
durante a primeira sessão estava aí que
alex mil anos não havia se o suficiente
na atmosfera para ver com a agricultura
isso vai virar e cultura nuno dias e
visam promover a propriedade aproveitar
na escola agricultura e todas fizeram se
constroem simples
não é que eu não via seu dorso fia na
atmosfera para plantar no ano não é
único no próprio
então temos algo juntos em lagos neste
planeta
mas quando você viu aqui do atleta só
nos últimos 10 mil anos ac quando diz ao
oceano separa a diferença gráfica em
termos de um período estável nos últimos
10 mil anos
é algo que nunca tinha acontecido
anteriormente no planeta e que nós fruto
destas alterações químicas caótica
realizada na atmosfera e sorvete se
transmitem os oceanos e fabiano será de
culto como um sistema 11 12 anos ou pelo
menos um dos regiões do insucesso nossa
abordagem nesta capital é preciso
aumentar nossa capacidade de tratar o
sistema teste como um tolo é que não é a
pior cidade um lado nem é o clima do
outro nem é um oficial do outro está
tudo junto
aquilo que nós fazemos hoje está uma
fera 50% dos senhores fmi por 11 anos e
fomos melhor começar de uma das nações
unidas não tem uma única linha sobre
acidificação dos oceanos porque não tem
de 44 fé
segundo a forma como nós até hoje
consigo o abordar esta questão mas
considera o fla ele consegue explicar
aquilo que eu estive aqui tentar nosso
lado direito temos o planeta é adeus 510
milhões
eu quero explorar os lados que temos o
sistema terrestre e um sistema que nós
temos hoje não foi um prefeito foi este
último período 10 mil anos que nós
estamos aqui a falar
outra questão que juridicamente até hoje
no flamengo é esta que os danos são
globais
não aqui nexo de causalidade entre o
fato eo dano
os dados são o mais são cumulativos
estamos falando várias gerações
as alterações climáticas estamos a viver
hoje não tem apenas a ver com a nossa
geração tem a ver também com outros
carros que estavam atrás de nós e que
com isso não se viu nada no que nós
temos a coisa é saber quanto isto é até
hoje é maior o desafio que se coloca ao
direito internacional numa questão que
não é apenas entre países que a global
em que cada um aquilo que faz dentro do
seu país tem feito mais
quero lembrar negativo queda nem vou
poder ter visto o uso ecossistemas que
eu tenho dentro da minha cidadania fazem
serviço que tudo fui acabou a não apenas
são jackson também os benefícios que
somos eu fui da escala global
ela vai seu alteram quimicamente a
atmosfera em parte dos anunciantes têm
impacto no clima porque é porque estão a
aumentar a temperatura do crime é o
efeito estufa que tem que existir para
manter o planeta g20 este período eo
luciano antes de dizer se não houvesse
intervenção humana na alteração química
da atmosfera provavelmente o assassino
era um período que se estende por mais
ou menos similares nós estamos nos 10
estamos a tentar usar nesta maneira
importante causa de ter os povos com o
aquecimento ao ter essa é uma dinâmica
que tem transporte e o equador e toda a
dinâmica que criar aqui correntes
oceânicas de cuidados médicos
altera-se e assista aqui que nós estamos
a assistir hoje três coisas diferentes
um território que é possível dividir uma
zona da água que nosso vir mas que entre
os países é possível chegar a um acordo
e que obter resultados e um sistema
teste que nossos visitou global e que os
200 países que estão aqui à volta como é
que nós podemos chegar a acordo quanto a
isto
isto requer inovação isto é formular do
direito internacional que é um direito
que tem como objetivo apenas evitar a
guerra entre países não paulo
não podemos usar essa lógica não podemos
usar esse modelo teórico para construir
uma expulsão mas está no bem comum que é
o sistema terrestre
a questão é que este sistema terrestre
onde não existe um time porque a
economia já mais tranqüilidade à
poluição extrema dado negativo isso não
é nada positiva os instrumentais não é
instruir aqueles que estão buscando
existe desaparece no no vácuo e como não
existe um sistema de resto tudo que eu
faço o sistema terrestre existe um
sistema de cartões já que não existe um
segmento com existe claramente um ponto
os dados que
o sistema testa não existe a economia eo
edifício também não hesita e portanto
essa cena thrash e hoje já temos forma
de medir o seu estado é que chama os
planetas valores que definem qual é a
estrutura viagem é o química do oceano
deste trio da história do nosso planeta
que se define por uma final da estrutura
do limite do faixas dentre as quais a
que chama os passos de uma nova surpresa
humanidade e este espaço de manobra
segura para a humanidade
é esse nosso patrimônio natural
intangível
isto é é uma natureza que não é um
espaço geográfico numa reserva natural
não é uma espécie de proteína é uma
estrutura bioquímica que é o nosso maior
patrimônio natural inclusiva e porque
não apenas impor limite quando surgiu e
os flaps valores com quem nós
trabalhamos apenas para impor limites à
atividade humana
por que não usar esses limites esta
faixa de segurança da humanidade para
incluir também tudo isto é o que tu faz
do clube que pokémon por que não incluir
os benefícios de nossos ecossistemas
fazem criar uma economia positiva melhor
número em que todos os países além do
negativo fazendo também positivo se
positivo não entrar nas contas eu não
vai existir nunca vai ser capaz de
recuperar o estado do nosso sistema
terrestre mas até hoje só trabalhamos
com limite só trabalhamos com quanto é
que tu vais polui menos e não também não
temos as contas quanto é que tu vais
fazer mais do que positivo para o uso
como quarteto vai mais fazer positivo
para manter o sistema traz tanta
experiência ali neste mapa temos as
áreas do planeta que neste momento são
passíveis de ser recuperadas qual é esse
capital natural que nós temos e que é o
mundo oportunidades no mundo ninguém vai
investir recuperar das suas florestas
mas o benefício de todos o custo é meu
ninguém mais se acredita ser o atalho
analógica sem os sistemas conta
em que falem de sabíamos qual é pegada
negativa que cada um faz do sistema
terrestre ensinou contra por exemplo
ficou com é pegada positiva
nós nunca vamos criar as condições
estruturais de perceber qual é o teu sal
no qual é o meu falou e eu vou investir
no meu positivo porque sei que o grupo
tem que inventar mas mesmo isto é que
meu positivos beneficiam todos pois
todos são capazes de compensar a mim
isto é o que nós chamamos o ecosoc
quanto é que cada um faz positivos
através do quanto é que faz negativo e e
isto é condição estrutural para
conseguirmos obter um acordo com isto
existir tem que primeiro existir
juridicamente o senado resta esta
senhora nossa foi uma senhora que tem um
prémio nobel da economia
só a trabalhar com comuns ela conta
lissah teoria que nós falamos ao
princípio a teoria de que só de lindo é
que nós consigamos vender as coisas e
criou mostrou economicamente que é
possível ter mais vantagens econômicas
na gestão dos comuns do que a exploração
que nós tivemos até hoje
hoje chegamos à conclusão que avance no
nosso planeta que nós não conseguimos
dividir estamos condenados e juros de
forma como ou nós somos capazes de
perceber isto em que há uma forte
interdependência entre todos e que só
com contas em crescente usado nem senti
um otário é que podemos chegar a esse
era o acordo
e estas pessoas voltarem é mesmo da nova
economia
ninguém quer ser o atalho e temos que
encontrar um sistema estrutural permite
que todos sintam seus entre as mentes
abordados e sol nestas condições que
constrói a confiança é esta confiança de
conseguir primeiro o comportamento do
outro e em função disso condicionarão o
meu governança global como bem não
exoplaneta não pode ser uma imposição da
alguma instituição que em cima que é
mais tem mais que ver com os poucos
estados têm que ser um sistema em que
ela estava sem cinto aos seus interesses
mesmo que seja
dodô comum mas saiba porquê do douro e
porque é que o qual é a lógica
e qual é o comportamento dos outros e
que permita que aquilo que está a ser
governado não é o planeta não é o estado
é o senhor terrestre estão condomínio a
nós misturamos dois tipos de propriedade
de um bem que se misturam se supõe estas
duas propriedades e que se tornam se meu
time dependente de uma da outra
estamos a falar do condomínio então eu
estou com medo da terra é que nós
estamos a propor para gerir o sistema
terrestre em nossa vida neste planeta no
futuro obrigado a todos